Since we're factoring by grouping, we want to look at these first two terms
first, 2z cubed minus 3z squared. The only common factor that they share is a z
squared. So we can rewrite them as z squared times 2z minus 3. Now, onto the
last two terms, negative 6z plus 9 has a common factor of negative 3. Now, of
course, we could have pulled out a positive three instead and left this as a
negative 2z plus 3, but I'd rather have a positive coefficient in front of my
variable, that's just a personnel preference thing. Now we just pull out the
common factor between the two terms we have left, that common factor is 2z minus
3 and then what's left over is z squared minus 3. And voila, we are fully
factored.